just an author panel with Christopher
Hitchens author of hitch 22 a memoir
William Gibson author of zero history a
novel and Sara Gruen author of ape house
a novel author and actor Patton Oswalt
is the master of ceremonies the program
was taped last week at the Book Expo
America an annual trade show for the
publishing industry
this program is an hour oh hi
folks thanks coming out to the be EA
lunch and my name is Patton Oswalt you
may have seen me on basic cable I'm not
used to being in front of a literate
audience this is a kind of new for me
I'll be at cranberries in West Virginia
next week featuring come on out six
rolling rocks for six bucks I I have a
book coming out next year that my
publisher told me that I should talk
about Oh although that it's it's a
little awkward to actually look at look
at hitch getting all the photog look at
that soaking up the fame such a rockstar
I have a book coming out next year I
feel a little weird talking about it
I've it's it's a still an ephemeral
thing in my head but it's basically a
collection of Wow one lady is taking my
picture oh that's that's so sweet thank
you nice with it all with a disposable
camera okay so um with a big 35
millimeter lenses yeah give me a little
oh don't get me under the chin though I
look all bloated and creepy oh like wow
why did Admiral Ackbar speak at the
luncheon that was weird good three nerds
in the crowd um basically uh I don't
really know where to start I've been
such a bookworm my whole life and this
is sort of my first book that's coming
out and I'm sure you guys have been
through this process and are kind of old
hands at it but it is sort of a big deal
for me and I and I don't really know
sort of what's going to
happen with it I guess I think the
weirdest part about writing the book is
as a comedian if I come up with an idea
I usually just go on stage and just kind
of blurted out and I get immediate
response and in writing a book as I
write each sentence I almost want to
send it out to 300 random people to see
if each sentence works which I know is
it is a terrible way to kind of write so
I'm sort of getting used to that process
which again I'm sure that these guys
have have been through and know all
about and also I've become a dad which
is very strange because I want my
daughter to grow up very intelligent but
now I don't know how intelligent I want
her to be and I'll just what I'm saying
is my brother-in-law babysits for two
kids in Chicago and they're they're
basically the prodigies that the parents
are geniuses the dad is a physicist and
the mom is some other kind of scientists
and the kids are two years old and they
speak languages and they do advanced
math and they play instruments and
they're just prodigies and at one point
my brother-in-law one of the but they're
still in diapers that's what's so weird
they wear diapers but they're reading
French so one of the kids at one point
had an accident in their diapers
basically and my brother-in-law went oh
do I do I got to change your diapers and
this two-year-old said diaper singular
which again that's that's the confidence
of a serial killer like if you if you're
defecating in your pants and then
correcting people on their grammar
that's just eating on a level that I'm
just not used to at this point so and
now of course I'm on I'm on Twitter
which I just I just love how we've
basically gone from MySpace which which
was this great thing for kids and then
all the adults piled on to MySpace and
all the kids went ooh this he's creepy
old people here and they ran over to
Facebook and then all of us jumped onto
Facebook
they went and then they kind of went
over to Twitter which is just Facebook
boiled
down to 140 letters that's all it is is
how how how boiled down can you possibly
make it and then and then I also have a
youtube channel which I've realized now
YouTube is is basically the beginning of
American society being Rome burning to
the ground because all YouTube makes us
is a bunch of bored Roman emperors
everyday and we basically wake up and
say what do I feel like amusing myself
with this morning but I like to see a
panda poop or perhaps a redneck we hit
in the scrotum I wonder it bring me a
panda pooping please that's all you do
basically is is just people being hurt
for our pleasure while we sit in our
pajamas and sip lattes any questions no
we're good
nothing to kind of ask me about huh oh
what's the book into me about it's
basically a Wow
thank you it's it's Sex in the City but
for just sort of fat shut-ins no that
will be that will be wow that was please
tell me that was mocking applause um
alright it's basically it's called
zombie spaceship wasteland and it's a
kind of a autobiography about my life
done through kind of humorous essays and
the whole basic central idea is and I'm
if there's any writers in the room out
there in the audience you know that
especially for that I guess the the nerd
portion of the population part of
growing up and becoming a writer is you
either write a book about zombies a book
about spaceships or a book about
wastelands because when you're 13 14
years old you don't know how the world
works so in order to write about it you
have to somehow either destroy it or
leave it
so you either go oh there'll be a zombie
apocalypse or it's a weird futuristic
wasteland or I've just left the planet
I'm killing mutants with a ray gun
because I'm frightened of girls I don't
quite know how
the social networks work so I'm going to
destroy them before I write about them
so that's folks the books a lot better
than the way I just described it by the
way there's all kinds of there's really
awesome stuff in it I'm telling you is
this the way you sell a book just kind
of go up in front of people and really I
wrote this book and it's awesome you
should totally check it out
all right here's Stephen King right I
will I'm going to end on I'm going to
end on a bit that made its way into the
Columbian valedictorians speech this
past weekend yes thank you Columbia
graduates um when I was in college I
went to a very liberal arts college and
it was the kind of a college that they
were very proud about the fact that you
know we create well-rounded students or
our science majors take English classes
and our English majors take science
classes and I was an English major and I
had to take a science class and and
basically and to this day my knowledge
of science goes no further than salt is
salty there there you go so but they had
a class in my college and I'm not making
this up I went to the College of William
and Mary and in my junior year they had
a class called physics for poets so
basically was like hey they're English
major weenie are you do you want to
learn about the music of the spheres
without any scary numbers we'll put on
some pantaloons and a scarf and skip on
down to a field of ghillie flowers to
the physics department where we'll teach
you about that about science without
using any of those frightening equations
that make you scurry under your bed and
shiver under the coverlet and you could
ask questions like is the red planet
Mercury like the crimson I am Cerberus
Lee yes whatever just sit down puffy
shirt will just get you through this so
the guy that taught the class was the
head of the physics department it was
clearly doing it as a favor to the
college they'd just go please just get
these get these English majors through
one science class
they can graduate and he taught the
class just just soaked in resentment
like his hatred for us you could have
drizzled it over waffles it was so thick
and rich he just hated us but for the
final exam I guess he just figured I've
been so mean this whole semester I'm
going to try to reach out to these wood
nymphs and be a nice guy
so he gave us the final exam were five
word problems and he really sprinkled
some English prose over them and and
tried to make them user-friendly and one
of the questions was Captain Kirk is
sitting on the bridge to the USS
Enterprise if the if a Klingon ship is
approaching at this speed and the
enterprise is going this fast that it's
basically it was a distance in velocity
problem in space and the question ended
with if if Captain Kirk
tells check-off to fire the phasers and
the phasers go this path so that's the
whole problem
so I'm sitting in the back of the
auditorium and this time my friend tells
it because he was sitting next to me and
he was like you suddenly stood up walked
all the way down to the front of the
auditorium and you're now at the
professor's desk and you're saying
something very specific and very angry
and very pointed and then you walked
away and the professor put his hands on
his desk and just kind of heaved himself
to his feet and slant everybody please
need your attention word problem number
five I've just been informed that Sulu
fires the phasers on the USS Enterprise
not Chekov if this made the question
impossible to solve I will change the
name of the crew member please hand your
blue books to my TA I'm going to go home
sit in a hot bath and open a couple of
veins screw all of you all of you die
please buy my book all right thank you
guys very much all right I'm going to
introduce each of our panelists I will
sit panelist like this is a game show
this first writer is a huge in in in my
world this guy is the White Stripes and
Bowie and a rocket that's made of
Cheetos that is how awesome he is to me
his new book hich 22 which they sent me
an advanced copy of and I've read it and
it's crack it's so good folks you know
him you love him ladies and gentlemen
mr. Christopher Hitchens
[Applause]
just a hint of tongue there ladies and
gentlemen thank you so much for coming I
was thinking when you were talking about
the title problem of flash back to me
the late English comedian Alan Coren
wanted to write some memoirs and he was
told by his poachers they don't sell
don't bother very discouraging about
wherever he went and they finally said
well what does sell and they said books
about golf books about cats and books
about the Nazis so he wrote a book
called golfing for cats which I had on
its cover a huge cat waving a golf club
with a huge swastika tattoo you know
it's all its Tommy and it was a
best-seller
so take courage I was asked to be brief
but I didn't realize that I'd have such
an enormous captive audience so just
relax everyone I hope has a drink and
something to read perhaps I'd like to
see you've all got it's 20 to make
yourself comfortable
I have no intention of being terse I was
also asked to talk a bit about what it's
like writing about life writing and one
of the things is you have to bid adieu
to economy normally I'm trying to
condense trying to lay out an argument
make a case see how much you can pack
into a few thousand with the fount of
memory unsealed however you throw
caution to the winds you keep
remembering more and more things you try
to get them down while you can and you
look for mnemonic devices and of course
one of the best of these and I have a
lot of them in the book is the Limerick
I know that a lot of you think the
Limerick is just a delivery system for
filth Genya
yeah filth that's what they want filth
and plenty of it
the humble Limerick coming can be used
as a delivery system for filth I mean
there's the young engine driver named
Hunt who was given an engine to shunt
saw a runaway truck by yelling out duck
saved the life of the fellow in front
that's not what you wanted is it that's
not at all what you wanted was something
filthy and preferably anti-clerical I
would guess strange how contemporary
that stuff is let's see it's a Family
Values gathering I'll keep it soft
though they say of the Bishop of
Birmingham that he screws little boys
well confirming him they kneel on the
Casa he lifts up his cassock and pumps
his Episcopal sperm in him ruff you'll
agree but hardly needs any bad words but
the real point about the Limerick is not
that I could go on in that vein but I
won't unless there's a huge demand for
it it's how much you can condense for
example the great Robert conquest who is
one of the many wonderful figures whose
friendship I honour in the book he's now
94 great historian of the Russian
Revolution and great poet and great limb
resist and he condensed the history of
the Russian Revolution into a limerick
which goes like this Russian Revolution
had a big influence on my life at one
point too so that's my excuse the once
was a fellow named Lenin who did two or
three million men in that's a lot to
have done in but where he did one in
that old bastard Stalin did ten in Suzy
doesn't leave much out five lines you'll
remember the speech the Jack gives in
the second act of a as you like it the
seven ages of man remember all the
world's a stage and all the men and
women merely players they have their
exits and their entrances each man in
this time plays many parts the form
being seven ages remember that this is
Robert conquest condensing those 24
lines into the following
seven ages first puking and mewling then
very pissed off with your schooling then
[ __ ] and then fights then judging chaps
rights then sitting in slippers
then drooling Shakespeare in one go you
can also do John Calvin's doctrine of
predestination in in a limerick once was
a man who said damn it's been borne in
upon me I am the creature that moves in
predestinate grooves I'm not even a bus
I'm a tram
they had and well and then there's the
wasteland quite easy to do if you're
Wendy Koch who I listed my memoir as one
of my favorite poets certainly my
favorite woman poet and she has the
wasteland like this in April one seldom
feels cheerful hot Sun and cold dusk
make me fearful clairvoyants depressed
knee commuters distressed me met Stetson
and gave him an earful now the wasteland
ladies and gentlemen so these I try and
include us as mnemonic devices but the
task of telling about one's life doesn't
get any easier in fact it gets harder
once you've once you've finished because
you keep on remembering more things or
things you wish you'd said since we're
talking in French it's done it's what
Diderot calls the the esprit de Scalia
the line you think of on the staircase
on the way down that you wish you'd
after the time it comes to you too late
sometimes called area pal say I was lost
yesterday why I decided to slightly out
myself and describe a gay episode in my
bride said regurgitated days at Oxford
University where one of two of my
conquests included delightful young men
who later became members of mrs.
Thatcher's cabinet and I was asked why
didn't why I'd chosen to put that in and
I said well I've been in favor of
screwing the Tories all my life
why didn't I put that in the book I talk
to myself about it
Jonathan Karp my brilliant editor and
publisher and one of the founders of
this beast said to me at one point this
there's quite a lot of sex but not very
much love in the book and I thought I
was thinking in blurbs by then I thought
immediately lots of sex but no love
Jonathan Karp 12 perfect birth almost
written for me if they say anyway they
say it's a good sign if you keep on
thinking about it that it's boring if
you put in if you put in everything the
other thing that I found is that there's
nothing quite like reading about your
own death someone referred to me as the
late Christopher Hitchens in the
catalogue of the National Portrait
Gallery in London recently and I thought
I'm not late mate but then I thought but
there's a sentence that will one day be
absolutely literally true and as Leopold
Bloom says in Ulysses it's a good thing
to read your death notice it gives you a
new outlook on life concentrates the
mind very wonderfully I recommend it
constant reflection on demise is a good
thing
now I'm trespassing on the time of my
fellow guests here I'll just I'll try
and end with another thought because I'd
like you all to read the book and I'd
like you to give it to your friends and
tell them not to take it out of the
library but to buy their own copy
because you there's much much more value
added if you if you do that and it also
hit me Asay and I wish I thought of this
before that hich 22 is also a telephone
number it's got exactly the right number
of digits as it were and if you just put
one 900 in front of it will you promise
write this down just tower one 900 pitch
22 and we can stay in in constant touch
and you can send my my children to
college and I and I look forward to it
and it's been very nice of you to be my
prisoner thanks so much Daniel
[Applause]
now unfortunately mr. Hitchens has to
fly to London which I so hope someday
someone says that about me like he wants
to stay he's got to fly to London
because you're a spy
for God's sakes you are literally James
Bond he's gonna he is going to leave now
to fly to London how awesome is that now
let's all watch him do it here he goes
there it christopher hitchens ladies and
gentlemen thank you if you haven't had a
chance to read the book the chapter
where he goes over some of the word
games that he and his circle of equally
brilliant friends play is so filthy and
so kind of reassuring to a comedian like
me that oh yeah
even really smart people try to find
ways to slip filthy words into classic
sentences I won't go into it but it is
it is it's actually kind of
life-affirming in it it's literally
pages they're just sheets of filth and
when you're done reading them you'll go
oh hey life's really great alright I
like it
now our next writer I I got sent your
book last week and I've been moving and
I haven't had a chance to read all of it
but I started reading it on the plane
yesterday and I read it the entire
flight I could not stop reading and I've
read the first I think ten chapters at
this point and and that's really saying
a lot because the in-flight movie was
the Tooth Fairy starring the rock and I
did not watch it
instead I read her book instead of
watching tooth fairy a fifth time so
that really the book is called ape house
I'm going to let you describe it but we
were talking about it backstage it's if
the beginning is terrific maybe it
stinks later on I don't know but the
beginning is awesome it is really
amazing
ladies and gentlemen be also the author
of Water for Elephants Sara Gruen ladies
and gentlemen
[Applause]
can everybody hear me okay is the
microphone right in front of my face
no okay well it's been three years since
I was last at BAE and it's hard for me
to believe because the time has just
flown and I actually as many of you know
intended to be here last year but
sometimes books take a little longer to
write than you intend and before I get
into details on the new book I want to
thank everyone in this room again for
everything that you did for Water for
Elephants it meant the world to me it it
made the book and as a direct result of
that
the film started but they started
filming the movie a week ago today so
thank you and it's got a dream cast of
Christoph Waltz and Reese Witherspoon
and Robert Pattinson and additionally a
lovely elephant named ty and speaking of
lovely animals it was just before my
water for all of us to her that my
mother sent me an email about the Great
Ape Trust in Des Moines Iowa and the
work they were doing there with language
cognition and acquisition among Apes and
there were two reasons that I was fast
immediately fascinated by this and the
first is that although I've loved
animals my whole life and and
particularly great apes I've never heard
of bonobos and the second is that
they're doing really really amazing work
with language acquisition and I had been
following the story of koko the gorilla
since 1980 which I well have just dated
myself but it was it's been a long time
that I've been interested in this and
but the bonobos I spent a day looking at
the the website of the Great Ape trust
and researching bonobos of it and
they're the most recently discovered
species of great ape only 1929 did they
get named as their own species they were
considered a type of chimpanzee before
but they have a completely different
culture and it's a really kind of crazy
culture there
they're maitreya matriarchal they're a
gala terian they're peaceful and they're
extremely amorous the average bonobo
initiates sexual contact of some sort
every hour and a half they it's like a
handshake they reaffirm friendship they
when they get excited about food
arriving they have an orgy before eating
it's no it's they really do so I really
just I decided right then in there that
I had to do the next book on these on
these creatures and I really wanted to
go and meet them as part of that so
apparently a lot of people want to go
meet the Apes of the gradate trust and
the trust weeds them out by giving you
tons of homework to do and making you
prove that you've done it and what part
of my there was a stack of books and
linguistic textbooks and things and I
also went to York University for a crash
course on linguistics and it wasn't ever
anything that interested me before but
when I came out of New York and walked
to the bus stop what I really wanted to
do was walk to the enrollment office
because I was just already so caught up
in the work that was being done and
listening to the vocalizations of
bonobos and them actually picking you
know words but I digress a little bit
because that's the bonobo language the
the thing that's important for for my
book is that the bonobos have human
language they understand spoken English
completely and they respond using a Lexi
Graham board which is it's a series of
symbols that represent words and on
their computers they press the buttons
and a synthesized human voice says the
word and they speak in complete
sentences and they use tenses and you
know they're grammatically correct it's
it's um it's amazing so I did my
homework and I grovelled until I got
invited to the trust and but I knew that
getting to the trust did not mean that I
was going to get to meet the Apes
because the Apes are in complete control
there and so I really tried to stack my
odds like the guy in my book I did
research on each of the Apes fav
toys and foods and I bought them each
backpacks and stuffed them with bouncy
balls mr. potato heads M&Ms and and had
them and sent an email to the scientists
saying oh please tell them I'm bringing
surprises and so after my orientation
and they were testing me on the books
and like yeah I did the homework can I
meet the Apes and so they went back and
asked the Apes and came back and said
well yes not only are they letting you
in they're insisting you come in so M&Ms
go a long way with apes and children but
um so Kanzi is the most famous of the
bonobos at the grade 8 trust and he's
he's a show-off he's a rock star and he
knows it so he came out and he was
talking on his keyboard and and and
playing music you know he's recorded
with very famous you know he recorded
with Peter Gabriel and Paul McCartney
and various other musicians and then I
met Pam Venetia who is very quiet and
she's although she's more linguistically
competent than her brother she doesn't
talk to just anybody
and I didn't know how to break the ice
I knew that Pam Venetia liked dogs but
not cats and I knew that she had two
sons so I brought a picture of my dogs
and a richer picture of my sons and so I
showed her picture of my dogs and there
was nothing when she wants to say no she
just there's no response and then I held
up a picture of my kids from when they
were much younger and they were all in a
bubble bath together and she immediately
punished babies washing bubbles in her
in her computer and it was that was the
first moment of two-way conversation
that I'd had with an ape it was just
really mind-boggling what I didn't know
at the time is that being a mother is
the gets you instant status and bonobo
culture because they the highest the
high infants are the highest on the
social hierarchy but so I spent I spent
the day there and they sort of dragged
me out when they when the scientists
wanted to go home and apparently the
next day Pam
Asia said where's Sara build her nest
when's she coming back
and so I want obviously I wanted to so I
sent them a fruit of the Month Club I
wanted them to remember me so this
particular family of apes is is what the
Apes in my book are are based on and I'm
trying to sum it up quickly because I'm
are notoriously bad at summing up their
own work but I guess I could say it's a
family of language competent Apes
who are torn from their home under
mysterious circumstances and then
resurfaced several months later under
equally mysterious circumstances in a
reality TV show situation recently I had
a chance to go back and visit and it was
a very different visit because of the
fruit of the Month Club they actually
remembered me and so I had many many
more conversations with them and they
were you know not shy at all and in fact
when I got there they said well if
you're really lucky you can go for a
walk in the forest with Pam Benicia and
I just thought that Wow and but then by
the next morning Pam Benicia had changed
her mind and we were to have a tea party
in the forest and so and so the other
Apes heard this and they got jealous and
they were they said well if she's going
to have a tea party with Sara then later
on she has to have a tea party with us
in the green tunnel and there was all
this you could hear all these this
yipping and squeaking and peeping going
on through the building as they were
communicating this to the to the
scientists and discussing amongst
themselves where this was all going to
happen meanwhile meanwhile Pam Benicia
heard that I was having my makeup done
and decided she had
and they gave her makeup and she
realized that somebody else was doing
mine so she wanted someone else to do
hers and so at one point she ended up
with very artistically self-applied
purple lipstick and powdered cheeks and
her makeup job on dr. sue was was not as
wonderful she removed it right away
because it was in red and we thought
that might give the wrong idea and
photographs sort of a slasher film thing
and but so we went out it took a long
time to get to the forest and I realized
later I found out what had happened is
that the people had set up the tea party
and Pam Venetia got upset and made them
take it down because she wanted to set
it up and she has her own kitchen and
she has a gas range and so she made the
tea
she chose Earl Grey for me and
Blackberry for herself and she spread it
the blankets and she knew I was coming
so she'd been saving cookies for a week
and she put out the cookies on the
plates and I we were using fine bone
china and she poured she poured the tea
and then she asked me very politely if I
wanted to milk and I said sure I'll have
milk and I put some milk in it and this
is where it got sort of very bicultural
by species so then she asked for the
milk back and went glug and just slammed
it and it was gone and this this was a
Tuesday and the bonobos have been
declared overweight so they're they have
diets on Tuesdays and Thursdays
so Pam Benicia then told me I should try
the candied ginger and dip it in my tea
and so I did and then she told me the
other cookie I should eat and so I did
and then she asked me politely for my
cookies and just tips the plate back and
ate all the cookies and then then she
just she thought about that for a while
and I guess she thought that that wasn't
fair so she went off into the forest and
she brought me a branch and gave it to
me it's sort of ceremoniously and the
it's I guess it's called brows I watched
one of the scientists eat a leaf hoped
that she hadn't faked it because to me I
was taking her word for it that it
wasn't poisonous and so I sat and
politely ate my my brows which would
have been much improved with some olive
oil
but then an another amazing sort of
linguistically important thing was the
way that Pam Benicia segwayed this she
looked at me and she said using her
board Sarah did you eat eggs today and
her favorite food is hard-boiled eggs
and I said no I didn't but I did
yesterday and she said the bunny came
last week and hid eggs in the forest and
she looked sort of pensively up and
thought said I wish the bunny would come
back and in the background I see guys on
walkie-talkies and five minutes later
the Easter Bunny comes traipsing out of
the trust with a basket of hard-boiled
eggs and so the bunny showed us what was
in the basket and and Pam Benicia was
visibly excited because hard-boiled eggs
are her favorite food and so then sue
the the head scientist asked Pam Benicia
pet Manisha kept trying to get up and go
and look for the eggs and and sue said
no and then she said would it be do you
think do you think sarah would be good
if we sent her to get an egg and Pam
Benicia thought about it and I was
thinking oh no I'm being set up for
failure here but she said yes and then
sue said so you think if she finds an
egg she'll give it to you and not eat it
herself
and Pam Benicia said yes so Sarah can go
get an egg yes so off I went into the
forest to get an egg umm and I came back
and she ate it very happily and at one
point she noticed that I had a bruise on
my leg and she got very concerned and
she was asking me how I got hurt and I
just I have a hundred and seven pound
lap dog which is how I end up with
bruised legs but so I explained to her
that I was okay and everything but she
really really wanted to groom me and she
was very concerned about this and then I
got I spent some more time with the
other Apes but we never got around to
the Tea Party and the Apes were upset
about this and so I was at an off-site
interview the day before I was supposed
to leave and 15 minutes to the well
quarter to five we got a phone call from
the trust saying that one of the Apes
was refusing to eat until I came back
and she was holding to her word so the
said well what time is your flight
tomorrow and so I got up early and I
really don't do mornings but for the
bonobos I do mornings and I got up early
and I went back to the trust I stopped
at Starbucks I got them all of Starbucks
and and I brought them each a coffee and
an apple and I went through and talked
to each ape separately and explained to
them that I had to go home to my own
nest in my own family but I would come
back and visit soon and the very last
thing I did was have breakfast with Pam
Benicia and it was just the two of us
and we were lying on blankets eating our
apples completely silently and it was it
was in this moment of silence where
there was no need for words that I that
I really realized just how very similar
we are and and that's what I hope I hope
will come out of this book that's it
thank you
buy my book
[Applause]
it really is an amazing book and
especially I wanted to mention you when
you showed up with the backpack full of
the stuff that you knew they would like
so they will let you in I just remember
when I was at the Sundance Film Festival
a few years ago and I walked into some
gifting suite and they were frantically
trying to get like the right kinds of
shoes and vodka and fragrances out on
the tables so that Paris Hilton would
show up like they had to make sure to
get her favorite things and I realized
oh it's just a backpack for a happy ape
that's all it really is they just get
her M&Ms in her bouncy ball and maybe
he'll show up and we'll get a picture
and that nice and she worked with a nice
little keypad too she was like you know
vodka give me it was it was really it
was really touching it was really
touching but then they tranked her and
it was it got really ugly so our last uh
writer of the day I'd really need some
introduction this guy coined the term
cyberspace right out of the gate and
then he kept a lot of people wouldn't be
able to uh follow that and he just kept
expanding and deepening this amazing
dark universe that he kind of lives in
he people also don't know he coined the
term bootylicious and wesen ality and he
does got not get credit for those and I
think that's wrong I think that's very
wrong ladies and gentlemen the reason
your kids are looking at a blackberry
and texting and not talking to you
mister William Gibson William Gibson
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
well
say it's midway through the final year
of the first decade of the 21st century
and say that last week two things
happened scientists in China announce
successful quantum teleportation over a
distance of about 10 miles while other
scientists in Maryland announced the
creation of an artificial
self-replicating genome now in this
particular version of the 21st century
which happens to be the one we're all in
today neither of these things attracted
as much attention as the final episode
of Lost now you know with quantum
teleportation there's no actual matter
transferred but information is can
conveyed across distance without
resorting to a signal in any traditional
sense so it's not really teleportation
but still it's the word teleportation
used seriously in a headline it's like
you know I'm reading this and saying no
kidding
teleportation but you know I only really
felt a slight amazement and that
synthetic genome in Maryland which is
arguably artificial life that felt less
amazing it's the sort of thing one
Fields might already have been achieved
somehow
or was that in a movie but it's
artificial life in Maryland but those
artificial life sciences scientists also
inserted a line of James Joyce's prose
into their genome and that triggers you
know the sense of the surreal for me
even though they did it for a really
practical reason they did it to
incorporate a yardstick a measure for
the ongoing rate of random mutation so
right this minute quite literally a
short length of James Joyce's prose is
being very slowly pummeled into
incoherence by cosmic rays but when I
found myself confronted with these two
pieces of more or less simultaneous news
my imagination which grew up on
countless popular images of exactly this
sort of thing could only produce a
tabloid headline synthetic bacteria in
quantum free space teleportation shocker
when I was when I was a boy Alvin
Toffler warned us about
future shock so is this future fatigue
and for the past decade or so the only
critics of science fiction I pay any
attention to all three of them have been
slyly declaring that the future is over
now I wouldn't blame anyone on first
hearing that for assuming that it's akin
to premature declarations that history
itself is over but really I think
they're talking about the capital F
future which in my lifetime has been a
cult if not a religion people my age are
products of the culture of the
laughs future the younger you are today
the less your product of that if you're
15 or so in 2010 you inhabit a sort of
endless digital now a state of a
temporality enabled by our increasingly
efficient communal prosthetic memory but
you probably don't know it because as
anthropologists tell us we have a very
hard time comprehending our own culture
the future the argument goes capital F
be it crystalline City on the hill or
radioactive post-nuclear wasteland is
gone up ahead of us now there is merely
more stuff events some tending to the
crystalline some to the wasteland e
stuff the mixed bag of the ongoing
quotidian now please don't mistake this
for one of those after us the deluge
moments on my part I've always found
those appalling and most particularly
when uttered by aging futurists who of
all people should know better this
newfound state of no future is in my
opinion a very good thing it indicates a
new kind of cultural maturity an
understanding that every future is
someone else's past every present
someone else's future upon arriving in
the capitalized future we discover it
invariably to be the lower case now the
best science fiction has always known
that but it was a sort of cultural
secret when I began to write fiction at
the very end of the 70s I was fortunate
to have learned as an undergraduate that
imaginary futures are always regardless
of what their authors might have
believed about the day in which they're
written or well knew it right in 1984 in
1948
I knew it writing my own first novel
which was published in 1984 Neuromancer
that novel though it's careful never to
admit it is set in the 2030s when
there's something like the internet
called cyberspace and a complete absence
of cellphones which I'm sure young
readers assume must be a key plot point
more accurately there's something like
cyberspace but it's called cyberspace
though I know that's confusing
I followed Neuromancer with two more
novels set in that particular future but
by then I was growing frustrated with
the capitalized future to me those books
were actually about using the toolkit of
science fiction to discover what I could
about the 1980s so I wrote a novel
called virtual light which was said in
2006 which was then to very near future
and followed it up with two more novels
he said a few imaginary years later and
what was really my take on the 1990s but
it didn't seem to make any difference in
how I was generally read lots of people
assumed I was still writing about the
capitalized future I began to tell
interviewers somewhat testily that I
believed I could write a novel set in
the present our present then which would
have exactly the effect of my supposed
imaginary futures hadn't JG Ballard
declared earth to be the alien planet
wasn't the future now so I did in 2001 I
wrote a book called pattern recognition
my seventh novel given the events of
2001
I quickly found the material of the
actual 21st century to be Richard
stranger more multiplex than any
imaginary future but still imminently
susceptible it seemed to me to being
unpacked with the toolkit of science
fiction complete with a workaday level
of cognitive dissonance we now take uh
Turley for granted zero history my ninth
novel will be published this September
rounding out that third set of three
books it's said in London in Paris last
year in the wake of our global financial
crisis I wish I wish I could tell you
what it's about but I haven't yet
discovered my best likely story about
that that will come with reviews
audience and bookseller feedback and
booksellers are especially helpful in
that way along with however many
interviews these things will serve as a
sort of Oracle suggesting to me what it
is I've been doing for the past couple
of years
if pattern recognition was about the
immediate psychic aftermath of 9/11 and
spook country about the deep end of the
Bush administration and the invasion of
Iraq I could say that zero history is
about the global financial crisis as
some sort of nodal event but that must
be true of any 2010 novel with ambitions
on the 2010 zeitgeist but all three of
these novels are also about that dawning
recognition that the future be it
capital T tomorrow or just tomorrow
Friday just means more stuff however
peculiar and unexpected a new quotidian
somebody's future somebody else has
passed but simply in terms of
ingredients it's about recent trends and
the evolution of the psychology of
shuri goods crooked former Special
Forces officers corrupt military
contractors the wonderfully bizarre
symbiotic relationship between designers
of high-end snowboarding gear and
manufacturers of military clothing and
the increasingly virtual nature of the
global market and I called it zero
history because one of the characters is
had a decade go missing ten years in
which he paid no taxes and had no credit
cards he meets a US federal agent who
tells him that that combination
indicates to her that he hasn't been up
to much good the past ten years but that
quotidian now finds him events find him
and he starts to acquire a history and
one assumes a credit rating and the need
to pay taxes and it's also the first
book I've written in which anyone gets
engaged to be married now a book exists
at the intersection of the author's
subconscious and the readers response an
author's career exists in the same way a
writer worries away at a jumble of
thoughts building them into a device
that communicates but the writer doesn't
know what's been communicated until it's
finally possible to see it communicated
and after 30 years a writer looks back
and sees a career of a certain shape
utterly unanticipated more stuff and
it's a mysterious business the writing
of fiction and I thank you all for
making it possible
[Applause]
that was William Gibson ladies and
gentlemen or was it I have a copy of
zero history I have not read it yet I
cannot wait to read it I'm going to the
Sasquatch Music Festival this weekend in
gorge Washington I'm going to walk
around with an advanced copy of William
Gibson's latest book that always brings
out the good mushrooms so I'm very very
excited guys thank you so so much for
coming to this luncheon I'm very excited
to be a soon-to-be published author I'm
sorry that I'm so giddy and just not
glib about it it's